everyone in the kingdom is very
impressed with your ability to help with
the party planning everyone except for
this gentleman right over here this is
arbeigla and he is the king's top
advisor and also chief party planner and
he seems somewhat threatened by your
ability to solve these otherwise
unsolvable problems or at least from his
point of view because he keeps over
ordering or under ordering things like
cupcakes and so he asks he says king
that cupcake problem was easy ask them
about the potato chip issue because we
can never get the potato chips right and
so the king says arbeigla that's a good
idea we need to get the potato chips
right so he comes to you and says how do
we figure out on average how many potato
chips we need to order and to do that we
have to figure out how much on average
does each man eat and how much each
woman eats and you say but what about
the children you say well in our kingdom
the king says in our kingdom we forbid
potato chips for children you say oh
well that's that's all and good well
tell me what happened at the previous
parties and so the king says you might
remember at the last party in fact the
last two parties we had 500 adults at
the last party 200 of them were men 200
men
and 300 of them were women 300
were women and in total they ate 1200
bags of potato chips 1200
bags of potato chips and you say what
about the party before that it says that
when we had a bigger skew towards women
we only had a hundred men
100 men and we had 400 women
400 women and that time we actually had
fewer bags consumed 1100
1100 bags of potato chips so you say
okay king and arbeigla this seems like a
fairly straightforward thing let me
define some variables to represent our
unknowns so you go ahead and you say
well let's let
let's let
let's let m
equal
the number
of
bags
eaten
eaten by each man by each
man and you could think of it on average
or maybe everyone and all the men in
that kingdom are completely identical or
maybe this is the average number of bags
eaten by each man
and let's let
w
equal the number
of bags
eaten
by
each woman
each woman and so with that with these
definitions of our variables let's think
about how we can represent this first
piece of information this piece of
information in green
well let's think about the total number
of bags that the man ate you had 200 you
had 200 men
200 let me scroll over a little bit you
had 200 men and they each ate m bags m
bags per man so the men at this first
party collectively ate 200 times m bags
if m is 10 bags per man then this would
be 2 000. if m was five bags per man
then this would be 5 000. we don't know
what m is but 200 times m is the total
eaten by the man
same logic totally eaten by the women is
300 women times the number of bags eaten
by each woman and so if you add the
total eaten by the man and the women you
get the 1200 bags
you get the 1200 bags so this is this
information written algebraically given
these variable definitions
now let's do the second with let's do
the same thing with the second party the
information that they gave us right over
here let's think about how we can
represent this algebraically
well similar logic what was the total of
the many that that the men ate at that
party it was a hundred men
times m bags per man and we're assuming
that m is the same across parties that
men on average always eat the same
number of bags
and how many did the women eat at that
second party well you had 400 women and
on average they ate w bags for per woman
so this is how 400 times w is the total
number that the women ate you add those
two together you have the total number
that all the adults ate so this is going
to be 11
1100 bags so it looks pretty similar now
you have a system of two equations with
two unknowns and so you try your best to
solve it
but when you solve it you see something
interesting last time it was very
convenient you had a i think it was a
500 here for 500 adults and you had
another 500 and so it seemed like it was
pretty easy to cancel out one of the
variables here it seems a little bit
more difficult the what's multiplying by
the m's it's different here the
coefficient on the w is different over
here but you say well maybe i can change
one of these equations so it makes it a
little bit easier to cancel out with the
other equation so what if for example
what if for example i were to take i
were to take
this blue equation right over here and
multiply it by negative two and you
might say well sal why why are we
multiplying it by negative two well if
we were to multiply it by negative two
this hundred m would become a negative
two hundred m and if it was a negative
two hundred
then that would cancel out with a
positive 200m when we add the two so
let's see what happens so let's just
multiply let's multiply this blue
equation by negative 2. we're going to
multiply by negative 2. let me scroll
over to the left a little bit so what
happens remember when we multiply an
equation we can't just do one term we
have to do and we can't just do one side
of the equation we have to do the entire
equation in order for the equality to
hold true
so negative 2 times 100 m is negative
200 m negative 2 times 400 w and there's
a positive right over here so it becomes
negative 800 w and then negative 2. now
we did the left-hand side but we also
have to do the right-hand side negative
times eleven hundred is negative twenty
two hundred
so just to be clear this equation that i
just wrote here essentially has the same
information we just manipulated we just
changed this equation multiplied both
sides by negative two but it's kind of
the same constraint what makes this
interesting is now we can rewrite this
green equation let me do it over here
this first one
200 m
plus 300
w is equal to 1200 and the whole reason
why i multiplied by negative two is so
that if i were to add these two things i
might be able to get rid of that
variable over there and so let's do that
let's add the left hand sides and let's
add the right hand sides and you could
literally view it as we're starting with
this blue equation we're adding this
quantity on the left-hand side of the
yellow equation to the left-hand side of
the blue and then 1200 is the exact same
thing that we're adding to the
right-hand side we know that this is
equal to this so we can add this to the
left-hand side and this to the
right-hand side so let's see what
happens so the good thing is the whole
reason why we multiplied it by negative
2 so that these two characters cancel
out you add those two together you just
get 0 m or just 0.
you have
negative 800 w plus 300 w well that's
negative 500 w
and then on the right hand side you have
negative 2200 plus 1200 so that's
negative
negative 1000
and now this is pretty straightforward
one equation in one unknown a fairly
straightforward equation we divide both
sides by the coefficient of w
multiplying w so
divide by negative 500 on the left
divide by negative 500 on the right and
we are left with w is equal to
w is equal to two on average women ate
two bags of potato chips at these
parties we're assuming that that's
constant across the parties so let's
think about how you would then figure
out how many bags on average each man
ate
well to do that we just go back to
either one of these equations in the
last video or a set of videos i look
went to the first equation i'll show you
that the second equation should also
work either one should work so let's
substitute back into the second equation
and you could either pick this version
of it or this one but i'll pick the
original one so you have a hundred
a hundred times m which we're trying to
figure out plus 400 times well we now
know that w is equal to 2.
400 times 2
is equal to 1100 is equal to 1100 so you
have 100 m
plus 800
800 is equal to 1100
and now to solve for m we can subtract
800 from both sides
subtract 800 from both sides
and we are left with
100 m 100 m is equal to
and now divide both sides by 100
100 and 100 and we are left with m which
is on average the number of bags of
chips each man eats is equal to three so
you have solved arbeigla's problem what
he thought was a difficult problem using
the magical mystical powers of algebra
you are able to tell the king in his
party planning process that on average
the man will eat three bags of potato
chips and on each and on average the
women will eat two bags of potato chips
each